how are you feeling these days i feel
really good yeah yeah this is now
your second pregnancy is this one
different than the first one do you feel
like this one's
easier yeah i mean you you have two kids
yeah with the first one
i don't know if this existed with your
first one but there were these apps
where you can check
daily to see the size of your baby based
on like fruit so like
right oh today my baby's the size of
guava or a banana
or like avocado and i did it every day
right
i couldn't even tell you how far along i
am right now i literally i'm like i
don't know a couple months no we had the
app
on our daughter was born first and we
were all into
today her eyeballs are growing you know
and
we're on the computer all the time and
on the looking at things and talking
about it and then the second one comes
ah this is 100 true i genuinely don't
know how far along i am like
somewhere between this and that with the
first one i would tell you the exact i
mean like literally to the t
how like what was happening the
formation of the eyes the tail is no
longer there like whatever it was i have
no clue what's happening with it i wish
i had kept my tail i really do
those things would come in handy i mean
grab a beer uh
no i'm sure it's funny i'm one of six
kids and i know that my you can see
like my parents there was all this
attention on the first and then
somewhat less attention second by the
time i came along they were just would
be born and they would throw us into the
basement and shut the door
you know were you are you the baby no i
was in the middle oh oh
yeah but they didn't even they still
aren't sure which one i am they're like
aren't you sean uh now how old
is your first now wyatt is 20
almost 22 months so 21 months okay
personality like easygoing
she's she's really funny and
incredibly bossy like it's weird because
you
they're just kind of developing their
language skills and she's somehow
mastered sit here now
so be like sit here now and you're like
oh my god my child's like a little baby
nazi like
she's she's really like
and then she grabs your hand if you
don't want to do it she doesn't care she
just pulls you down to the floor
so she's just in charge she's like let's
make this happen let's go let's go
she's very strong-willed